ladies and gentlemen we have a new
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson Trump
Ally so sayith CNN has been elected
house Speaker 3 weeks after the McCarthy
ouer okay it's big news people are
asking who is this guy and uh what's he
going to do and videos are popping up
both of him being epically based but
also mercilessly cringe some people are
arguing that he's woke some people are
arguing that he is a an Ardent Trump
Ally Who defended him during impeachment
and those things are true but then
there's like a recording of him saying
things about you know critical race
Theory type stuff and people question
him but uh I think I think based on what
Matt Gates said recently on Steve
Bennett warm there's really really great
stuff happening and this is a tremendous
Victory uh the long story short of it is
that Kevin McCarthy was secretly
sabotaging things and and removing him
from power was the right move so either
way seeing push back in any degree I
think is a step forward now we need to
see action so we'll talk about that we
got a bunch of other stories a crazy
video coming out of New York Jewish
students at Cooper Union locked in a
room as far leftists bang on the doors
they were locked in there for their own
safety and escorted out through tunnels
in fear for their safety and there's
there there's a bunch of stories about
this there's a report that a police
Source has warned Jewish people in New
York to avoid certain areas because of
the pro Palestine marches I just think
it's it's it's getting out of control
it's crazy a lot of people you know they
get super heated about this but we
absolutely talked about this last time
when you had that wave of violent crime
against uh hidic Jews in New York and
Orthodox Jews who were being beaten and
attacked this is this is the complaint
about the far-left they this is this is
what they defend and this is what they
do so we'll talk about all that before
we get started my friends this show is
brought to you by cast brew coffee if
you want the best cup of coffee you've
ever had you go to C brew.com and you
pick up C Brew Coffee we've got apple
Lin kns whole bean and ground we've got
rise with robberto JR this is our
company we sponsor our sponsor ourselves
and we're in the process of building our
first coffee shop why to create a
physical location for people to gather
share a cup of coffee and it's also a
way to protect ourselves we're going to
sponsor ourselves we're going to build
new companies that reject wokeness and
this far-left garbage and we're going to
start companies that believe in American
values so with that being said we're
huge fans of Public Square as well and
this is all part of that process if you
want to support our work get your coffee
from as.com but also don't forget to go
to
timcast.net
to our Discord server where like-minded
individuals like you can hang out or
even not like-minded maybe you want to
argue with someone it's a it's great fun
there's pre-shows there's after shows
special content available to members
only and that's where you go if you want
to ask us question so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all of this is Ron
Coleman how you doing is it Ron Coleman
Esquire
or not really no you know I'm a lawyer
but who doesn't know I'm a lawyer the
only reason you ever use Esquire is
either as
a sort of
semiformal honorific to someone else you
know it's like doctor but for lawyers
but doctor like doctor but for lawyers
yeah but uh but when but when you're Ron
Coleman the
lawyer you're Ron Coleman what do you
need who know listen I get I get out at
the quick check in
pic and the guy with the paper cup
outside collecting as we say is hey
loyer and he's not even on social media
okay he just knew just knew you just
some guys you can just tell so is uh uh
is that your introduction do you have
anything else you want to add to your
line of work or storyed career I'm Ron
Coleman well all right we also have
Brett dvic hanging out what's going on
guys yes I am Brett dvic I am the host
of Pop Culture crisis Monday through
Friday 3 p p.m. Eastern Standard Time
that is new Pacific just come hang out
with us also is there like a lawyer walk
like a special walk yeah is there like a
walk that they you know there might have
once been one but we're in a time now
when all of you know all the admissions
standards all the any anyone can be a
lawyer you know so I I don't think so I
thought maybe the the homeless guy knew
that there by the walk that there was a
well I I think it's more
like the radiation of a certain kind of
light no I it's not the walk and you
know I don't drive a BMW either so we
got Libby hanging out I'm back I'm back
in Ann's chair how's it going everybody
I'm Libby Emmons with the post
millennial and human events.com glad to
be here and I'm surge.com and ready when
you are Tim here's the big news breaking
history being made Trump Ally Mike
Johnson elected house Speaker 3 weeks
after McCarthy ouster the Republican
house uh LED house elected rep Mike
Johnson as The New House speaker on
Wednesday a major leadership change that
comes three weeks after McCarthy was
removed Johnson a vocal supporter of
former president Donald Trump and a key
Congressional figure in the failed
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
will now take the Reigns of the bitterly
divided House of Republican majority and
faces the looming threat of a government
shutdown next month as be interesting I
mean I think I don't know if this was
him but didn't didn't he say something
about getting funding for for foreign uh
foreign aid for Israel or war or
something maybe that wasn't him I don't
know what I'm seeing but I'm curious
what's going to happen what's the first
thing they're going to do is it going to
be Government funding and and is he
gonna go the same route as Kevin
McCarthy and go for the is is that a
recording of Me no it's not a recording
of you I actually thought I thought I
was I thought I thought I had this on I
wanted to see what what what the live
chat looked like oh okay and uh son of a
gun yeah because it's always amusing
it's turn the volume now yeah but I'm
wondering what's yeah he did semi
is one of the features all
everyone knows I'm a lawyer and everyone
knows that I'm am brain damaged okay all
right well you're doing you're doing
you're doing well but uh the question I
suppose is is Mike Johnson going to be
based or cringe it's like schro Jinger
speaker right now we don't know yet he's
like he's in a temporary stasis well we
wait to figure that out yeah I mean it
is kind of fun to to see people
pretending and liby and I were were
talking before like we're not neither of
us is going to
pretend oh yeah of course Mike Johnson
never heard of him never freaking heard
of him and and I've like been a you know
I guess I'm not like a politics junkie
like some people but I'm pretty
interested in
politics and maybe that's why they he's
the one who got the speakership because
everyone's just like I don't know enough
about him to complain so he's like last
round draft pick at this point they
tried everyone else and they can't get
any body else to get through cuz we were
just talking yesterday saying like we
don't know how long this is going to
take and selfishly me I was like yes
less government spending is going on
right now will we wait for this to get
figured out but now yes I do think
they'll end up turning back on
government spending I don't think
there's going to be a shutdown now you
don't think so you think they'll get
something checking it out and apparently
Johnson has been skeptical toward
Ukraine of late though he supported them
initially and supported us funding for
Ukraine initially and now he uh is
interested to know
where our money is being spent which I
think is a good thing I think we should
know where the $13 billion in less than
two years has gone as for Israel he does
seem much more
pro-israel um than who than for example
then ukra you know then ilhan Omar or
Rashid or some of the other Squad
members in the house um and he says the
US unequivocally stands with Israel will
provide support and resources necessary
to rid the world world in the Middle
East of Hamas it's not just going to be
Hamas it's going to be it's going to be
World War II well that may be but that's
where Mike Johnson stands so what's the
scenario how's it World War I how does
that how does that happen there's two
scenarios that have been presented by uh
that I that I that two two prominent
scenarios I've read one was from Ben
shapir and one was from a former
military Chief out of the UK Ben
Shapiro's position is if the US does not
get involved then you're going to see an
escalation between Hamas and Israel
which results in in Hezbollah and
Iranian backed militias attacking Israel
Israel's retaliation will result in an
escalation eventually pulling in Iran
entirely unless I didn't hear the world
that sounds like a regional conf once
Iran is involved Israel then resorts to
the Samson option nuclear weapons or or
or counter invasions into foreign
countries which turns this into a Iran
then calls in its allies Saudi Arabia
gets involved and one by one dominoes
begin falling now that's Ben's argument
uh I'm probably not giving it full
Justice uh was is a super smart guy and
I read that from him but the the
counterargument is if the US gets
involved it will result in Iran then
directly getting intervening in the
region which then brings in Russia etc
etc okay Russia not a not a thing
anymore you don't think Russia's going
to back Iran Russia doesn't Russia can
barely take care of itself in Ukraine
they don't have the resources and and
and their their military capacity has
been so severely demonstrated to
be Hollow I mean their weapon systems
their command control what but elaborate
on that what do you
mean
they the one of one of the main reasons
their
armor has failed so magnificently and so
many of their so many of so many things
that they were counting on happening
have not happened is
because the corruption lack of training
and lack of
resources has not been fully appreciated
by the leadership but that's that's
that's the history of Russia that's
exactly right the Napoleonic Wars that's
exactly right War one and two so the
only way the only the only deterrent
Russia has now as a counterweight to any
pretty much you know to a to a first
world military like the United States or
Europe
is nuclear but even there's there are
serious questions about whether even
their nuclear
deterrent
is like you can't just take a snapshot
of 1989 and say okay well they still
have those missiles yeah but if if
they've been if they haven't been
maintaining them and upgrading
them right them were in other territory
it's not only that well what the hell I
mean they'll shoot off a bunch of them
right
no you have to know when you use nuclear
weapons you have to know exactly what's
going to happen yeah there's a certain
margin of error but this doesn't doesn't
I don't think that that counters the
point that if the conflict bleeds out
Beyond Ukraine if the US gets dragged
into four or five different War fronts
then you have a World War well if the
United we're already at war with Russia
right well that's that's that is true
and I mean my my I'm just
curious historically when we looked at
conflicts in the Middle East there was
this concern of the Soviet
Union which had a welldeveloped
relationship
with Arab
clients until the 80s and that began to
crack up in the 80s um acting as a
counterweight to the United States and
and you know that had a lot to do with
the way Wars ended in ' 67 73 and in the
80s but Russia isn't the Soviet Union
and the relationship
I mean China is is more of a but but I
still don't think this addresses what
we're talking about I mean there I don't
think the argument is that there is a
gigantic Godzilla monster we're scared
of what we're we're concerned about is
dozens of Nations entering conflict
that's the world war it's it's not like
it's not like we're in this cold war
scenario where it's like the Soviet
Union and the us are going to start
firing nukes at each other the concern
is we're already at war in Ukraine we
are facing a potential War uh over with
China and the in Southeast Asia and now
we've got the Middle East bubbling up
and the US is sending massive fleets I I
think they announced uh the many more uh
destroyers uh ships are being sent out I
mean I I think the relevant question for
almost everyone watching and listening
is I don't really care I think most
people are saying which of these Middle
East countries have at each other when
we talk about I'm afraid of World War
III what we really are saying is are
Americans going to be
involved well that's the part we want to
that's the
part well we've got 19,000 Personnel in
the Mediterranean not including the lat
latest deployments and we've got troops
recently deployed into Europe into
Poland with our active uh we have
special forces operating operating in
Ukraine so so so all I'm saying is I
think that's I I'm actually making to
some extent an argument about
terminology because I because maybe it's
because I'm an old cold warrior when I
hear World War II I think you know know
the big one and you're you're you're
agreeing with me not we're not really
talking about the big one we're talking
about a more than local conflict no
we're talking about the big one we're
talking about the big so I haven't heard
that yet but I I think in it sounds like
what you're saying is there has to be
one gigantic bad
guy I'm I'm saying that the United
States
is not withstanding all the damage
that's been done to the military and in
terms of Readiness and all the
things is the sole hemon in milit in the
in military Affairs in the world there
are competitors but there's number one
is Far and Away the United States the
two carrier groups that are already in
the
region are already Untouchable by pretty
much
everyone so the question
is does the United States get to do
whatever it wants or does it have to
worry about a meaningful in other words
all right well that is we have to worry
about Iran yeah that's a good question
if can the United States do whatever it
wants or does it have to worry about um
you know enemies who could take it down
in certain ways I mean the thing about
the haven't we seen that though hasen't
hasn't like I'm I'm not remembering
exactly but didn't we have ships in the
Middle East at one point and they were
taken down by Iran with like you know it
was like a David and Goliath type of
thing and they took us down with not
little well there there was I think
think uh there was an attack it wasn't
Iran I'm sure paid for
it means now that would be bu
administation paying it through for it
through through Iran I think that was uh
that was
um yes there was like a a ding a dingy a
d you know rolled up but in terms of an
oldfashioned in other words what we're
talking about here other words there's
always going to be that counterforce you
know or that that unconventional warfare
um you know
uh Guerilla type of risk that that's a
given the question I think that that's
really interesting one
is does
Iran say to itself we're going to attack
we're going to attack American
shipping uh or or rather American Naval
assets because
they're enabling the Israelis to
embarrass our clients in
Gaza in other words will they take the
role that Russia took when I was a kid
and said you you know Israel's
embarrassing the syrians we have to now
threaten to to get involved it is it's
it's reported across the board that uh
us bases have been attacked by Iranian
backed militias using drones other means
injuring dozens the US has announced
that they will respond to this and are
sending out more assets into the region
the US asked Israel to delay their
invasion of Gaza to allow the US to
deploy more personnel and uh uh Patriot
missile systems and Thad
systems those seem to be specifically
for Iran the concern being that as soon
as Israel invades Gaza then Iran is
going to ramp up in some capacity and
maybe it's just through militias but the
US considers those consider considers
those already to be Iran and it's
sending out missiles to prepare for
conflict with Iran and it's not just
about Iran it's about Iran Russia China
and any other country in between Queen
it doesn't need to be one big baddy the
US is scared of it it needs to be that
we're already at war with Russia no
question we add in multiple fronts and
you have World War World War II was not
just Hitler you had you had the Pacific
Theater as well which is literally would
brought us into the world world war
Japan was not our big baddy no one no
one ever talks about um um what I forgot
his name what was the name of the
Japanese emperor in World War II yeah we
we don't go like can you talk about the
atrocities of H nobody cares
Hitler and Germany no no no what I'm
saying is in America culturally we say
Hitler and Germany they were the big bad
guys even though it was World War and we
were pulled into it because of hiiro
right so we could be pulled into a world
war that involves xijinping or whoever
else and I I so so my my take on it as
just you know just a lawyer in New
Jersey okay I'm I'm not a military
Affairs expert but I don't believe chi I
don't believe China
considers it worth it to them to get
involved in this militarily I don't
think Russia has the capacity but I do
but I none of that it's ch's not going
to get involved don't you think China
could get involved with Taiwan and then
Biden had said that we will military
militarily defend Taiwan and then
like yeah I mean could we potentially be
um spending in Ukraine we already have
guys on the ground in Ukraine and keev
like the Special Forces guys could we be
spending and like having guys in the
Middle East and spending and having guys
in the South China Sea is that a that's
a likely scenario that would look like a
World War to me so are you saying that
China would would opportunistically
opportunistically yes say well for the
us all right so which then results in
Vietnam losing it because China's
already been blowing up Vietnamese
fishing vessels claiming the South chin
sea is their own South China Sea is a
gigantic issue and then you get
Australia then you get South Korea you
get Japan the the region erupts now you
have massive regional political uh uh
Warfare hot conflict in Southeast Asia
in the Middle East in Eastern Europe
World War and didn't we just give
Australia or sell Australia a bunch of
nuclear subs well thaten there was there
was that was a while ago so I vaguely
remember the details but I do know that
the US has been working with Australia
specifically because of China and Taiwan
the US needs base of operations for the
region what people need to understand
when it comes to Taiwan is that Taiwan
is what is it like 70 miles or something
off of the coast of mainland China so
for the US to be able to defend Taiwan
you need a place to have your ships and
refuel your planes and that is massively
if difficult if not impossible
considering mainland China is literally
right there and they're going to have an
endless supply stack it all right next
to the shore and they're going to be
like I can do this all day now if they
move on Taiwan the fear is that Japan's
going to lose it South Korea is going to
lose lose it Vietnam's going to lose it
then then you've got all the other
smaller countri you've got Indonesia
you've got Singapore you've got uh uh uh
the
Philippines so but is the argument that
they would otherwise not do this if the
US were not paying attention to what's
going on in the Middle East if we weren
my feeling is like when I think about
China being opportunistic I think um if
the US weren't so extended they wouldn't
have the opportunity to go doing that I
I hear that but I I do think that China
moving on Taiwan is an inevitability the
issue is just that the US seems to think
Joe Biden jenet Yellen we can afford two
Wars we can afford three Wars well yeah
that do they believe that we can afford
three right like what better time is
there to wait are they literally waiting
for a third conflict we're not going to
go on the third one we're going to go on
the fourth one right like is there a
better time for them to do that when we
are as overextended as we are right now
I don't I mean are we are we
overextended I believe we I mean in what
way like I
believe no no no I don't I don't mean an
adjective I want to hear I I want metric
are we financially yes we are oh
financially I didn't know that I I
thought that we just print money now I
didn't realize that that was a factor
well when they're talking about it when
they when they were talking about they
were talking about financially we can
afford three Wars when we know that we
can't we are overextended we have a
military presence defending the borders
of Ukraine and not our Southern border
and that is the definition of
overextended well no that's I I can't
agree with you on that because that's
just a definition of bad
policy the reason that we're not doing
anything about the southern border isn't
because we're out of money it's because
there's no will to do it I mean that
that's a that's an an entirely
purposeful I mean to say that they spend
the money when they want to spend the
money they're sending people to Texas to
cut the wires right that prevent
immigrants from coming in that costs
money that's it's a matter of that
that's a policy Choice they're like 31
trillion in debt 35
but I think it is really important to
Define our terms so when we say
overextended I mean financially it's a
it's a freaking disaster that but there
is no there is no consideration
whatsoever I mean we spend like we've
been spending like a drunken sailor you
know for for 10 years when's the last
time an actual budget was
passed we don't we don't do that no in
this country debt ceiling I want to jump
to this story Let's uh let's let's bring
it back home because this is kind of
crazy we had this tweet from yasher Ali
Jewish students at Cooper Union are in
the library as protesters pound on the
door listen with the sound on he says
this is this is crazy
listen so they're chanting free free
Palestine while banging on the door
trying to get into a room where they've
secured a handful of Jewish students and
uh let me see what tweets we have Carol
marwick uh says Jewish students had to
be evacuated via Tunnels for their
safety in New York City City uh look I
think the farle I think they're deranged
I think they're psychotic I think
they're dangerous mobs we saw that video
out of Minneapolis where they attacked
the elderly man in his car chased him
down and then tried breaking out his
windows all because he was like there by
accident oh sorry you kicked the power I
did something yeah you kicked the plug I
did it wrong anyway yeah they tried they
they they would they'd kill this guy
yeah they because what happens is it's
the no flake in the Avalanche what I
talk about all the time I don't I don't
think it's fair to say that your average
person at one of these protests has the
has the motive and intention to kill a
person what happens is someone walks
down the street and one person shoves
them the next person runs up and kicks
them again each of them thinking I'll
kick the guy but after getting kicked
five or six times you're dead yeah and
so this is what you see when this guy is
pulling out through this car I think I
think these students if that door was
open would have been mercilessly beaten
and hospitalized do anyone have the
slightest idea what these
protesters reported to want to do with
the students well that that's the funny
thing of what you what you talking
earlier about language right so when we
talk about it here what scares me the
most about this is the use of language
so they're not saying hurt the Jews
they're saying free Palestine which
gives them a sort it allows them to put
like to terroristic threaten these
people without understand without having
to admit that what they want to do is
hurt another person because it's it's
changing the language ever so subtly so
that you don't have to feel as if you're
threatening someone or making
terroristic threats it's very different
and you can make these kids believe that
what they're pushing for is actually no
don't anything they don't believe
anything these people are not sitting
down and discussing the merits of the
region that is not what's happening
every one of the protests I've ever been
to with these leftists 90% have no idea
what's going on my favorite moment one
of my favorite moments was during Occupy
Wall Street and what they would what
they would chant the the Communists
would chant Auntie capita Lista they' go
ah auntie aunti capista and okay I get
it and you would hear 90% of the people
saying adiga bisto cuz they have no idea
what's being said let's go Brandon and
so there's a live stream I've got where
I asked the guy I was like what are you
chanting and he's like oh I'm I'm
chanting with him I'm like I know what
are you saying and he goes oh I don't
know he just tries to walk away
giberish nonsense they're that's why
those people are so dangerous they're
mindless zombies that's say if what they
were if what somebody had got them
chanting was a direct threat to the
people in that building would those same
people have followed through and
continued bashing on the door you
believe that they would I believe that
have like I I have been to these riots
the most rabid of them yes no no no no
no the most bol of them the most of them
I have I have seen people who showed up
not even knowing what PR was happened
Chuck a brick at a cop because because
when when when when the Avalanche begins
they're all doing one small thing they
don't find unreasonable a single person
picking a brick out of the ground and
chucking it a person is an extreme act
but what happens is one guy I I this
happened in I think it was uh I can't
remember where it was might have been DC
one guy starts pulling bricks out of the
ground he walks to the ground and then
he starts like chipping away at The
Brick another guy walks up and then pops
it up another guy walks grabs it then
one guy toss it to a guy then the guy
gets and just throws it that guy has no
idea what's going on not that that was
not the actions of one person who
consciously decided to pick up a brick
and then throw it at a cop it was a
bunch of people screaming in Anger not
paying attention and then all of a
sudden someone tosses a brick to him and
he catches it and he just Chucks it
without without a second thought look
when they went to Tucker Carlson started
banging on the door or when they when
they went to Cassandra Fairbanks house
with a bunch of fireworks and started
blasting at her house then the media
lied about it even happening listen the
problem here isn't these animals their
problem but that not the problem the
problem is that the institutions that
have been given and accepted the
responsibility for protecting human
beings from
animals have refused to do so well and
they've refused to do so not just in a
physical sense right they' refused to do
so in an intellectual sense so the
institutions that are supposed to be
raising our nation's leaders to be you
know thought leaders to be intellectual
to be critical thinkers to think deeply
to examine all sides of issue to make
decisions in a good and appropriate and
moral and ethical way they have
abandoned their obligation to do that
and they have instead force-fed them
indoctrinated them in these wasteful
ideologies that are intent essentially
on destroying American culture and
Society yes that's true but this is that
is not what we are seeing here no these
are monsters these these students don't
know what's going on don't care what's
going on all they know is one of their
friends says are you going to the
protest they went K and then they said
here's here's this here's the time and
the date and they showed up then people
started chanting something so they
chanted along the people banging on the
door right now that individual banging
on the door just thinks they're making
noise they don't think in their mind
they're terrorizing people MH but the
other people behind them hear the
banging and the fervor and they're
Imagining the people banging on the door
are trying to bust it down to hurt
people M so when the door finally breaks
open and they all rush in one person in
a mask is going to run up and smack one
of the Jewish students and then someone
seeing that will start filming and
chasing after and then you I've seen
this in person I was in San Jose the
Trump Rail and I watched them beat one
of their own one of their own protesters
so what happened was why did they do
that they did not know who he was and it
did not matter the moment he backed away
he became an other to the Mob and they
chased him and started punching him why
because he was running that's it they
chased him down punched him in the mouth
and I and and then I was he's like I'm
I'm I'm I'm here protesting Trump they
they punched me he bleeding from the
mouth there's a crowd of people one of
these guys and that's why I said like
these things are ridiculously dangerous
it's
mindless when a scuffle breaks out I'll
give you another story I was at uh
Columbia University Mike cernovich was
speaking this is several years ago and
one person in the crowd recognized me
and didn't like me so he yelled that's
Tim P do not let him film you so you
know what I did when he pointed I looked
with where he was pointing cuz I know
how these mobs operate everybody turns
into my in my direction and they're
looking for the person against them so I
turned with them and I'm going like
where's he at and everybody's shrugging
like where's he at and he's like this
guy right here and I'm like and then
someone walks up to a random
photographer and starts screaming at him
about he's the problem and I'm like cuz
they couldn't identify the other cuz I
know what these what happens at these
events you go to one of these protests
and if you are discernably other one
person will push you then as soon as the
fighting happens and you start running
away they'll start chasing after you for
no reason just because they're like oh
they're running I'm running then when
they see other people running after him
they'll be like what's happening what's
happening why is he running get him get
him then they shove you down and start
kicking you literally for no reason
right we've seen this in our literature
for years too I mean it's in Orwell it's
in Kafka diffus in Ray Bradberry lowski
was in uh was in Germany we were in uh
Hamburg during I think it was the G20
and Luke was B was was with a German
journalist walking down the street when
some random dude yelled Nazi schwein
hund at him and then he was like what
and then all of a sudden random people
who were sitting on the ground ran up
and started punching Luke in the back
and in the head and then Luke and this
journalist not Nazis were there just
filming things started running people
were chasing them they made it to First
Responders who then treated them for
scrapes and bruises and it's and and
watch Luke's video of this it's a
question of why did these random people
who were just sitting on the ground run
up and start punching Luke for no reason
this is what these mobs do so you're
saying they're just driven by themselves
they're just like driven by it's like a
feeding fzy like a sh sh piranhas it's
it's or Shar that like watch the video
of the of the car in Minneapolis that
drove through the protest very slowly
nobody got hit as soon as he starts
driving away people will run after the
car and it's it's an uous it's a person
will have a camera and they'll run
towards the car just to film it people
behind him see him chasing the car so
they chase then the whole crowd sees a
bunch of people running and they all run
to see what's going on eventually they
surround the car and then someone goes
that's him no one has any idea or any
information and then one guy who hears
that thinks he must be a bad guy and
starts kicking and stomping on the car
other people join in old guy in the car
is freaking out like why am I being
attacked and then tries to escape
imagine what it says to to these
students to when the university does not
have the people protesting violent
violently removed but instead has to
evacuate them as if they were being
rightfully targeted rightfully targeted
right so what does that say to them that
they're not actually there to protect
you the one who's being assaulted the
one who's being you know we saw this in
University of Washington as well so
there were these big basically pramas
protests at the University of Washington
and some students were speak like a Dean
was there and some students were
speaking to the dean saying you know
these people want us dead they want to
kill us and the dean was trying to get
the students the Jewish students who
were complaining about it who were in
tears trying to get them to move on and
stop complaining about it so that the
pro terrorist mob could continue their
protest which they're doing in your live
chat right now by the way oh really oh
my God I mean there are three or four
people who just keep repeating the
same thing I mean it it's it's wild I
don't welcome to the internet yes well
you have become a crypto Jew uh that's
not true Cassandra Fairbanks are Booker
proves that we're actually anti-semitic
no no that's that is so you're both Jew
and anti-semitic at the same time that's
amazing well that's okay because the
Jews are both uh are both um you know
control the world's muddy Supply and and
also SC people who who are scavengers
who live off
the uh you know let me let me let me
pull up the story from uh C love I'm not
familiar with this outlet but they wrote
police Source beware of Eastern Parkway
this chabus I hope I'm pronouncing
correctly you got it you nailed it uh it
says a pro Palestinian protest has been
planned for this chabus afternoon near
the Crown Heights neighborhood this is
um yikes this is from this is from today
and they say the flood Brooklyn for Gaza
protest is scheduled 3 p pm. this shabas
at the Brooklyn Museum in Crown Heights
and is expected to draw large crowds in
support of Palestinians and Gaza quote
Jews should definitely avoid the area a
police source told Co live there's no
Intel at this time in which direction
the protest will head locals should
definitely stay away from Eastern
Parkway in that area now the question of
course is it's hard for Jews to avoid
Crown Heights well sure but the question
is is this like what's the source you
know I mean no disrespect to se if I'm
not familiar with them should we believe
this let me tell you this right now if
there is going to be a leftist pro
Palestine March and you are Jewish you I
I would I would tell you uh uh and and
it it sucks to say but you are in danger
from these people I think so too no
question so this is Crown Heights Crown
Heights is where the laich
um um the booklyn museum is basically in
Crown Heights and there were riots in
Crown Heights that's where the Crown
Heights riots took place during the
dinkin
administration um he told the police to
stand down Eric Adams won't tell the
police to stand down he can't
really it's not on well he ran on a I'm
going to get tough on crime ticket yes
and he's also been he's also come out
very strongly in a way that bill
DeBlasio certainly would deasio doesn't
know what strong
means he certainly doesn't
know you know the a lot of things that
bill doesn't know right but Adams has
been has been good and he is a former
cop um but it is a this is a gigantic
strain as we were actually we were
talking about this before we started um
this is a strain on the Democratic
coalition
but in New York of all places um there's
going to be a very high see the thing
about
laum is they they don't back down um
they're the only Jews left in Crown
Heights which in the 50s as late as the
50s and 60s was a very
significant Jewish neighborhood that had
many different kinds of Jews in it every
other Jewish Community for all practical
purposes left Crown Heights when as they
used to say the neighborhood changed uh
but the the the the grand rabbi vavich
the re the
rebi uh Rabbi
schneerson um of said we don't we're not
going to run we're we're this is our
neighborhood and we're staying here uh
these are these are tough guys they're
they're you
know the problem is they're a minority
Jews are not actually
particularly handy in the United States
with um
self-defense but on the other hand a lot
of lessons have been learned the idea
the the idea that the New York City
Police would permit an encounter between
the you know uh casim of
laich and this protest um is insane they
we don't know which direction they're
going to go in you got to make sure you
know what direction they go in and you
got to make sure it doesn't go in the
direction you think there'll be violence
in Crown
Heights I I really don't think so but
but then again a lot of things have
happened that I never thought would
happen yeah uh we have this tweet from
Nikki freed she's of course a Democrat
running uh for governor in Florida
chairwoman of the Florida Dems she
responded to a video we just talked
about in the previous segment Jewish
students at Cooper Union College have
been locked inside the library for their
own safety as a mob of anti-israeli
protesters blocked the doors she said
this is outrageous are not Israeli
students right she said this is
outrageous and we are seeing these types
of videos and stories all over our
country we live in a civil society where
this is not only not okay but illegal
and everyone has a responsibility to
stand up against hate speech let me also
be very clear anti-israel is
anti-Semitism the Democrats are going to
be ripped to shreds this election cycle
over this issue really you think so
absolutely Nikki freed is trying to win
over Democrat votes in Florida and she's
coming out in defense of Israel good
luck now a lot of a lot of prominent
liberals have have begun to push back on
the left we had uh and people in pop
culture how look at the Harvard students
who came out there was there was at
Blacklist against them because they're
they're they're Pro Hamas and and it was
not just Pro Palestine it was them
calling the Hamas the resistance
fighting back I mean this is crazy stuff
if you're a Democrat and you need that
10 to 20% of progressive left vote and
you are pro-israel you've lost it no
question these people are fervently
anti-israel there were also 3,000 UK
artists who signed a letter that was
basically Pro Palestinian pro- ceasefire
anti-israel it's so we were talking
about this yesterday the amount of
celebrities I've watched come out and
try to find Middle Ground only to be
torn to shreds on both sides has been
truly incredible to watch as what 3,000
of them sound signed the letter to Biden
two days ago that said that yes the
Hollywood people right so a lot of those
people who are like leftists uh or at
the very least they vote Democrat all
the time right and they're realizing now
just how fractured aspects of the party
that they've supported for all these
years actually are because they're
seeing something they've never seen
before it's like I said earlier I will
never be more amazed at the idea of the
people who've been calling people Nazis
for four years breaking down and doing
this it's absolutely insane but I just
don't think that a lot of the the
celebrities who maybe they they vote
Democrat but they don't pay super close
attention to politics other than orange
man bad right they don't really look at
it that closely maybe they follow their
local Governor's race or something like
that but they didn't realize if you're
not super politically aware if you're
not following what's going on in the
news you wouldn't know this was
happening it's kind of the same way when
we were talking a while ago about what
was happening in England a couple years
ago when uh the the Muslim population
was protesting lgbtq stuff within the
school districts there that was so
fascinating right so it goes a lot to
that same they don't realize that there
is fracture within their audience
because they it's a weird type of
cognitive happened in that's that's been
happening in Canada too I think it's
because they don't pay attention so uh
we have we have this idea it's a really
good idea it's a game show U I think we
should do it so maybe we should need to
get someone who's going to start setting
it up it's a trivia political trivia
game show where we get left versus right
and we ask basic topical news questions
and then we see who gets the most
correct answers maybe a little history
maybe a little modern history no of
course yeah for sure like who built the
the Berlin Wall this would be this would
be interesting because like what would
happen is I think both sides would I'm
correct and they would cite their new
source which would be CNN and then
somebody else would cite another source
or they would just citing sources is it
doesn't matter the question uh that I
like to cite is what was the name of the
Ukrainian prosecutor fired after Joe
Biden threatened to withhold $1 billion
in loan guarantees of course the left is
going to say huh and the right's going
to go Victor
shoken and it's like well another
thousand points for or the left will
just say that didn't happen and you'll
like actually it did happen and you'll
have to explain it you're you're wrong
so so the lefties won't come on your
show because they will not they will not
be confronted with facts they will you
know how many times I've tried to get
people from the left on on my show of
course but my point the point I want to
make going back you know outside of the
the game show question is Tara Strong
voice actress very wellknown like one of
the most famous voice act actresses of
Our Generation Harley Quinn Batgirl
Timmy Turner you name it uh she was very
woke and very left despite the fact the
left has been saying for a decade plus I
mean for a long time that they want to
end Israel Patrice cers 2015 black lives
matter saying end the imperialist
project that is known as Israel
and and and she didn't care she didn't
care when people like I or you or any of
us said calmly hey like this is not this
is not good you shouldn't support these
groups no she blocks you she says screw
you I'm I'm going to stay in my lane and
and keep getting my paychecks until they
attacked until Hamas massacred a bunch
of civilians and that's part of their
Doctrine to kill civilians and capture
them for as bargaining chips and when
she got mad and tweeted this is an
outrage they fired her yep they fired
from her job really didn't even tell her
didn't even tell her she found out on
social media just tweeted she's no
longer going to be voicing this
character on our show with without
without even like seriously you got a
problem with someone sweet you talk you
call them on the phone first nope and
she was shocked she was so shocked by
this and you know it's like what
happened to Gina corano yeah but Gina
corano did nothing wrong right like ter
but Tara chose to side with people who
are evil and have for a decade been
longer than this but prominently calling
for an end to Israel and she IGN ignored
that because at the time what she was
protesting or what she was virtue
signaling about had nothing to do with
it so it didn't matter at that time if
it's BLM they're worried in 2020 about
what's going on with black lives matter
and George Floyd but it's just that the
chickens had not come home to roost yet
cuz now we're here you know there's a
famous poem that's kind of about when
you don't speak up for other people and
what eventually happens to you but I'll
tell you something wait Amy Schumer
wrote that
right well speaking of Schumer
that was exactly the point I was going
to make you know frankly there is no
group in America that is more
responsible for this state of affairs
than the
Jews the Chuck Schumer of the world the
liberal doners who have been screaming
about how the the ADLs of the world what
we have to worry about is white
supremacist white nationalism ignoring
what was seething and bubbling and his
Tim said all you had to do was pay
attention they refused to do that
because they're on a team and their team
they replaced the faith of their
ancestors with the the faith of FDR
interesting and the American the the the
the Church of the American assimilated
Jew is the Democratic party and Democrat
and Jewish institutions that have been
so profoundly
influential because of the ability of
Jews to succeed in so many areas of
endeavor all the things that you're that
these lunatics in your live chat are
going on about the disproportional this
yes it is true that Jews are
disproportionately represented in areas
requiring incredibly hard work high
intelligence and diligence uh
surprisingly to people who are
unfamiliar with those Concepts but not
surprisingly to the rest of
us
Jews have been in a position to stop it
from happening and they have not only
let it happen they've enabled it someone
like Chuck
Schumer nothing is more important to him
than maintaining his personal position
of power and privilege in the United
States Senate so that he let the Iran
deal go through
he was given permission to meekly wave
his hand about it if that if if Schumer
had not wanted it to go through it would
not have gone through you mean the $6
billion no I'm talking about the
original Obama deal going back yeah yeah
APAC like the entire exist purpose of
the existence of APAC is to prevent
things like the Iran deal they did not
prevent it because they didn't want to
rock the boat with the Democratic party
have Jews woken up probably not never
feels like they never feels like they
ever any group I just want to mention to
people uh we have been absolutely paying
attention to the uh uh what's going on
in Maine oh the shooting there yeah but
there it's like I just want to you guys
know just there there are multiple
scenes some people are concerned it
maybe a tear attack two active Shooters
in different locations some reporting up
to 16 have been shot but we we don't
know anything right now other than
that's that's all I can say I mean
there's nothing else to be said right if
if you're in the area in uh was it Leon
Le man yeah uh lock your doors and stay
inside is what the police are saying I
guess when it comes to Maine you don't
have to worry about any
Jews or even or Arabs being involved I I
I don't think that's true yeah I think
that's true I don't think that's true
anywhere in the country I I I I I don't
want to say too much but I believe there
is a potentiality that this is related
to Israel palese could be there's also I
mean there's been a lot of illegal
immigration across the Canadian border
oddly um New Hampshire just put together
a coalition or something to try and deal
with illegal immigration yeah coming in
from the north so there has been there
has been a lot of that also you see with
the immigration situation you've seen
the Biden Administration literally
flying people all over the country to
disseminate the 7 million people that
they want to come into this country for
some crazy reason uh in as many
different places as possible but to what
you were saying earlier like why why
they vote for something why they vote
for the Democrat Party democratic party
when you feel like it may be going
against interest but it's also like
think about what they do in Chicago they
they they get rid of one guy and they
vote in another guy who's going to
implement policies just as bad high
crime areas don't vote in like I feel
like gone of the days and maybe I'm just
young so I don't understand but like I
don't see New York go ever going back to
somebody like Giuliani or you what I'm
saying like I don't feel like any of
these bigger at least the cities the big
cities that have large uh like a large
condensed group of people I don't feel
like they learned their lessons well the
middle class has left these cities you
can only to live in New York City you
have to either be very wealthy I left in
January after like 20 something years
and you were I remember hearing I said
in January that was the last middle
class person and that was you that was
me yeah CU I have like a chart at my you
know in my let's let me pull the story
as we get into the subject and then
we'll we'll we we'll jump back Daily
Mail reports new save San Francisco gets
4 million in funding from billionaires
even as more than 40,000 crimes are
recorded across the city this year and
office vacancy rates are at
34% and then you see my favorite is like
now you see these like I love when the
media puts out these propaganda pieces
it's like the most uh the people with
the happiest the happiest places to live
in America and it's all of these cities
and you're like how is that possible
when the crime is this high and you look
at the index about like what actually
they constituted to mean happiness and
it's and it tends to be things like
abortion rights
all these other things babies exactly if
that makes you happy then that's fine
but it's like nobody learns their
lessons in these cities anymore I just
don't see anything changing of course it
like I said it could be because I'm
younger and I just don't have the
perspective of however many years yeah
you look San Francisco can be saved how
really with the billionaires the bilon
there there is a there is a billionaire
who could save it which one El musk no
which onee Donald Donald Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump could yeah he saved
New York City so julani juliani was
great sure sure but Donald Trump is is
credited with turning a New York round
you know you know about this Ron you
know about this right tell me this
particular narrative so as The Story
Goes New York in the 80s was was a crime
ridden hellhole I mean and into the 90s
you had the the subway vigilante that
people were cheering on because they
were so sick and tired of the crime and
uh it's crazy for me to have to to look
at these photos of the old Subways of
how it used to be that wasn't the ' 80s
that was that was the that was the 70s
it was and and that it was Ed cotch who
who began the process of
reclaiming the ' 80s was the turnaround
decade for that so the argument for
Donald Trump's involvement was that he
start he's it it really is a simple
story property was cheap there was an
opportunity to create this uh vision of
up like upscale New York living Donald
Trump started to build and develop in
the area and TR and work to convince
many other wealthy people to come back
because it was the cool place to be and
this is where you needed to be with all
the luxury brought back tax revenues and
that's that's that's the very very very
simple version I watched like a a
two-hour documentary breaking down the
real estate development and how it
started to change neighborhoods I I
could see
a a narrative that says you know among
the people who made a change were Donald
Trump but the idea that Donald TR you
know I I was there I was
there and it was interesting that Donald
Trump was building luxury housing and he
there was also a very remarkable
incident there was something there there
was a skating rink in Central Park mhm
that had been that fall into disrepair
like everything in New York did in the
60s and
70s and the New York City had been
utterly unable to repair it they could
not wman rink it was called this is a
great story right I love this one
utterly unable and then just just you
know because all these work rules and
all these unions of Donald
Trump who's in the time was just Donald
Trump okay he just was this guy who who
you know who is a real estate developer
says I can do this and the the the C
Administration says all right Wise Guy
see you do it and in like three months
he fixed it up he fixes it up like it's
like and it was this this great free
enterprise story that you know see what
a can do person can do if he's not
working for the go and and it it was and
that really put him on the map in a sort
of political way that he had not
previously been at the time
but you know New York New York is one of
those places that you can hardly ever
really learn any lessons from that are
applicable to in other words New York
New York is its very own place right
when I grew up the the Garment District
was a place where garments were
manufactured New York was still an
industrial city and it was a shipping
hub neither of which it is at all
anymore well during Co I remember cuz I
had extra time on my hands there was a I
was always I lived in Bay Ridge and I
was always seeing the I would like ride
my bike down the greenway and there were
the um massive Ships coming in like
those huge cargo ships there were a ton
of them and then at a certain point it
stopped for a while and I was like
that's not good well but there's very I
mean the shipping just kind of like
dried up for is now basically done in
the port of nework and Elizabeth right
you see those giant
things so New York Harbor wasn't deep
enough to be container ey to take the
big a lot of reasons it had also had to
do with the corruption of the unions on
the on the Docks but the merchant
marines the point which is still you get
you got like you got like family
connections to get into the merchant
marines
still the thing though is that New York
despite this despite losing its
industrial base and its and its
transport
significance the way all the great
Northeastern cities did because it had
been a um a a center of
Finance Wall Street kept New York alive
and through
the90s injected me you know when
deregulation came and Wall Street
started becoming the racket that it is
now Ma and that happened and then
between cotch and
Giuliani the rebuilding of New York into
a tourist Don um um uh destination MH
was you know best case scenario you're
never going to make
Cleveland or Philadelphia that kind of
destination they simply doesn't have the
attraction right so New York you can't
even if even if it were true that Donald
Trump did this in New York San Francisco
is it of course actually San Francisco
does have the the tourist aspect to it
but I mean look our my law fir Dylan Law
Group Dylan Law Group um our
headquarters in San Francisco that's
where most that's where most our first
of all we can't even hire support staff
in San Francisco anymore really why not
they people will not work in the city in
San Francisco I saw this Wild video
today of this woman who was just in
tears and she was like I just got my
first nine-to-five job after finishing
College oh yeah you must have seen this
yeah we we talked about it uh I I can't
believe it how do you have time for
having a personal life
if you work a night to find job I was
like that video Yeah are no when we when
we started watching that like I was like
okay dunk on this girl right but it's
like look she's she not she's not wrong
but she's also she's also young and she
will she will eventually the the pain of
coming home from work when it's dark out
will scab over and she'll just
understand that that's the way go to the
bar yeah like the rest of us it's very
easy to like to dunk on stuff like that
cuz that's my first thought was the same
thing like look you got to work that's
the way the world Works s you just have
to go to work but sometime but when I
watched that it's like look she's if it
was like her first day after her first
nine to-5 shift it happens she'll change
so uh just we're trying to be careful
with this about about Maine there are
some high-profile accounts tweeting that
uh uh some photos of the suspect have
been released oh I'm seeing that too
many people are saying it's a uh two
individuals of Middle Eastern descent
it's very preliminary there's a police
go go ahead sorry the suspect does look
like they may be Middle Eastern the
photoos released I don't know for sure
um and there's a police scanner video
going around of what appears to be
dispatchers or someone the police saying
two males one armed with a gun Middle
Eastern descent maroon SUV but we don't
know that any of these things are real
and I bring this up because uh you know
if you're in the area you need you need
to stay safe I don't know if this
information could help but I will say if
people are putting out fake information
you need to make sure you're count
you're you're looking toward towards uh
trusted sources and directly to law
enforcement if you're in the area but uh
the the big concern right now is like
there are some parody accounts tweeting
this video this could be a fake clip of
a of a police scanner because people are
just trying to se chaos which is
horrifying and ter it's it's terrifying
I don't know for sure but a lot of
people uh are saying they've seen
similar things outside of this and a few
high-profile accounts are saying Middle
Eastern uh described as Middle Eastern
so that's that that that's it for now
it's not confirmed don't know please
stay
safe that that you know that was
basically why when you were like it's
you know Maine probably not related I'm
like at just because the guy's middle
eastern doesn't mean it is related but
there's with what we've seen so far you
know there there's one story we didn't
pull up where a guy broke into the home
of a Jewish Family in California and was
threatening to kill them so yeah that's
crazy too do you want to live in a city
right about now you know where I want to
live is West Virginia it just never
have guns now the more that I see all of
this stuff in all of these and that's
what I'm saying like they don't it
doesn't seem like every voting cycle
they ever learned their lesson right
these places become more crimer ridden
with every election cycle it gets more
remember when how long ago like like a
two months ago when Kai sonat did like
the PlayStation 5 giveaway like 20,000
people showed up and just hundreds of
thousands of dollars of damage gets
done but but look this is my point that
that dude did a a PlayStation giveaway
and people started riding and destroying
and attacking people people are getting
beaten up in the street why there's no
political cause there it doesn't matter
because people go in insane in large
crowds so basically cities were just the
bad cities are just the problem it's
it's people being condensed not people
do you know what's crazy not all people
go insane in large crowds well not all
people do but there I mean I think that
it is I think that everyone has the
capability for to become a monster it's
true that not all people do thinking you
I mean it's do you think you do do think
I do oh for sure I don't think you do I
think I I mean I think if I don't think
I do I am at greater risk of becoming a
monster than if I it's not it's not just
being a monster in large in large crowds
people are not just being violent
they're also just being very very stupid
so going insane is not just about a
person deciding to smash a window it's
people acting in irrational ways okay so
uh I got to tell you
something there are people and and
includes everyone in this room right now
who will never be swept away by that
you're you're correct but it's it's it's
a small number and you have to be aware
of the five of us well you know what the
the thing is having having been on the
ground and and again I I assume First
Responders can probably speak to this
way better than I but having been in
numerous uh uh conflict situations urban
conflict civil unrest I can tell you
that out of the 500 people in the crowd
you'll see three act
rationally that's and and the rest are
just it's you wonder why someone would
do such a thing like um you ever watch
Indian January 6 by the way no January
6th frankly there were
people it was dumb to go in the first
place it was an OB it was an obvious
trap whether you whether it was meant
set up as a trap by the government or
not I'm not even getting into but you'd
have to be a schmuck I
think but people who did not go there
looking to make trouble definitely lost
their head but it's it's not that's not
that's that's not necessarily what I
mean uh have you ever seen the movie
Prometheus no have you guys seen
Prometheus Brad of course seen all of it
okay you know the scene when the giant
ring ship is rolling forward and okay so
it's a gigantic spaceship it's a big
donut and it is rolling and there is a
person running in the line of the ship
as it's about to crush them and they get
crushed and you ask yourself like that
was dumb why didn't they run to the left
yeah and it's like I wonder why and and
it's like it kind of P you're like
that's stupid if I was doing it
psychology let me tell let me tell you I
have been at many riots where people
have been shot and everyone runs
straight down the line of where the
person is shooting and being chased and
I've just been like why do they do that
because people just go insane public
panic and andix and my attitude is just
like why did you not turn left and like
just break away from the crowd and you
you may be more able to think like in a
in a high pressure situation you may be
more prone to thinking rationally than
other people are well I think it it it
could be experience yes but I think this
this is my point is that it's not just
about whether they're going to attack
it's about the general breakdown of
cognitive function and right now we're
in a society like a lot of these they're
young people right uh we have a heavily
medicated Society we have a very very
Doris Society right now where kids are
angry kids are upset they're being
constantly bombarded with fear porn
about climate change about all of these
things they're told the world's going to
end in 12 years by politicians and you
wonder why people are so on edge and so
easy to push to violence or push
to always referring now on strike for
Gaza the well-respected and highly
accomplished um writer for legal
Insurrection Jane Coleman who is Mrs
Coleman my wife um is always referring
to the work about uh crowd Psychology by
Elias Kennedy and he deals with but what
Tim is talking about here is the the you
know and and in his work he really
expands the application to of crowd
psychology
to a tremendous number of phenomena in
society um but he would you know you
should look at that book uh Tim and tell
me what's in it besides what because
between you and Jane I'll have to I
don't have to read it oh he won the
Nobel Prize in 1981 that guy he he was
he was quite it was quite a big deal
interesting very you know and and and
that's what we're talking about here is
this the the madness of crowds mhm um
and you know I I don't want to and I
don't want to be um you know unrealistic
about it I recognize that that but but I
do think that you
know people who are more civilized will
act more civilized in large numbers and
people who are less civilized will act
less civilized in you know in large
numbers
and we once thought we had a
civilization here well we did have a
civilization when we built bu it and we
built it so big and so strong that it's
taking a long time to crumble and then
what happened was we started saying we
should work really really hard to make
sure people who are unwell can continue
to be a part of our society and there's
but there's good things about that we
want to help people survive right well
there's there's the unwell I mean public
there's what's happened to public spaces
in general this that's the San Francisco
story right is that we gave up the the
idea that a society is entitled to
to not necessarily act cruel cruy
towards people who are unwell but to
protect itself and its spaces and its
children and its vulnerable people
people and its vulnerable people from
those who are unwell that's one issue
then there's the other issue of the
importation
of
premodern societal units that's a crazy
crazy thing that's happening right now
the importation of as you say pre pre
what did you say pre premodern societal
units you I mean that is pretty wacky
and then and then also refusing to
encourage assimilation and telling them
that their culture is better than ours
well so there's a story that I I I was
told I can't remember where I heard this
about a Saudi Arabian town that had a
lot of oil and uh for the entirety of
their their their small Town's existence
it was very
tribal no computers phones none of this
stuff and then when oil was discovered
they were all of a sudden very very very
wealthy and they did not adapt very very
well to having Mass wealth and what
happened was they were just covered in
gold chains and rubies and jewelry to
them when you when when you're in living
J the status symbols were not fancy cars
was not Big Sky was in pen houses it
wasn't the luxury infinity pool it was
gold and chains and things like this and
having your jewelry so when they got a
lot of money they just Amplified
everything that was about luxury to them
so they ended up just covering
themselves in gold and uh that was
basically explained to me as like what
happens when you abruptly just give
maximum wealth to one group of people
and it's and it really is it's
regardless of uh uh the level of
development this this Behavior exists
and and it's obvious because you can
only know what you know for instance if
you go to your average American and give
them a ton of money what are they going
to do they're going to buy a big house
they're going to get a big pool they're
not not going to act outside of societal
Norms lottery winners why so many
lottery winners end up losing most of
the money because they did not uh how
they end up getting to it they don't
actually know how to invest or how to
build the wealth but it's not just that
it's like you know Elon Musk wants to
build a spaceship the average person who
gets billions of dollars doesn't build a
spaceship yeah they they want to do
things that they they that they believe
is luxury and and their desire so nice
cars big houses you know big big
properties and things like that many of
them don't go and buy horses but horses
are are expensive and horses can be
consider Dr of fan no no it's they don't
act outside of their their culture so if
you bring people into the United States
that go from an impoverished City in you
know Honduras into the US they're going
to with access to these resources
amplify them in a way more more akin to
their society and less akin to to to
ours
right it's not about level of
technological development right if if if
if they have certain behaviors when they
get money they go out and have this
special kind of party with 13 kinds of
booze or whatever they'll do that same
thing here and then we'll say things
like shouldn't they be taking care of
their house and whatever shouldn't the
people in this small village be
installing plumbing and like buying cars
and building roads we're so shocked they
buy gold and jewelry and
gems fun of the novo well okay but I I
think on the other end of the scale
the point you're making
is the fallacy of
liberalism one of the great fallacies of
liberalism has always
been poverty is what makes
people
misbehave and the fact that's still the
line why do people why do Palestinians
from
Gaza Massacre people and and burn them
alive poverty it's asine it's an asinine
rap well that's that's an that's
extremely I think poverty is a huge
component of it's a component but the
point is you have
societies that have lacked
wealth forever and have nonetheless been
stable nonviolent like what
um
well the Eastern European Jews were
remarkable poor in the 20th century and
certainly those in the pale of
settlement in Russia um but they were a
minority they were a minority so it's
maybe not a very good example but well
no no no look look society and so and so
was Yemen for example the AR Moroccans
and Yemen in other words much of much of
the of the of the Middle East before the
Western Powers started screwing things
like before the 40s I would say really
before the TW before well before the 40s
I'm say you know the 19th century 20th
century you know it's when
the they were they were dirt poor these
these you know these these were really
remember petroleum is not a factor so
there's no reason you know it's been
it's been Millennia since spice Roots
mattered right and and petroleum is not
a thing yet so what is making Arab
societies wealthy nothing they're not
wealthy they're poor
but I mean homogeneity is is an issue
also but the point is they had stability
and they and you don't have to be poor
to
be you know uh to be violent or to be
unhappy or to or to or to or to
misbehave socially a big issue in
America right now it's not about wealthy
in Port it's about wealth inequality
which has become a big striking point
for a lot of those people right well I
think that's it right that's why the
point I was going to make is if you go
back 200 years what what is the saying
uh you have better a poor person has
better Dental Care today than
rockafeller did you know 100 whatever
years ago technological development so
now poor people have air conditioning
they have refrigeration they have clean
running water and they have Cheetos they
have Cheetos I mean America Taco people
po we have fat homeless people that's
right poor poor the surviving get
getting the calories you need to survive
is not an ISS
issue uh no there's plenty of that right
in fact it's an issue that we get too
many this country has too much too many
calories too many calories we got to get
rid of some of those calories but so
much of it is is like you look there are
large social programs for people who are
unable to pay for food who are unable to
pay we do take care in a lot of ways our
social programs do cover a lot of that
but there's still this large call for
discussions about wealth inequality that
leads to violence at a lot of these at
least what it seems like to me right
like a lot of what we're talking about
it's telling you the Millionaires and
the billionaires oh sorry it's just the
billionaires now because Bernie Sanders
he's a millionaire but yeah it's that's
the the ring cry we have this big story
that's breaking today about crime a
crime that must be addressed breaking
Jamal Bowman to plead guilty to pulling
firearm in capital in exchange for
charges dropped $11,000 fine in
sweetheart deal we got him there he is
ladies and gentlemen insist the
insurrectionist has been apprehended I
mean this was this was 911 all over
again you know when when he when oh yeah
it was it was worse it was almost as bad
as January 6 give you that sweetheart
deal if you go you mean January 6 was
almost as bad as this yeah you know
because nobody pulled a a fire alarm on
January 6
to that's horrific but they were saying
that September 11th was not as bad as
January 6th remember that oh yeah oh
there's still people there's still
people that say that yeah their argument
is they were subverting democracy
there's people that believe
staying within the Velvet ropes well
right this is it Jamal Bowman says I am
responsible for activating a fire alarm
I will be paying the fine issued yeah
okay is it his first offense because I
think that's fair I do is it absolutely
first offense I don't know Tim soft on
crime I don't know about that let's face
it what he did is is literally an
offense against democracy it actually he
was trying to stall he was trying to
prevent a vote from get place in
Congress and it's been treated like a
misdemeanor false
alarm you'd think he was just
trespassing in the capital that would be
I remember I was um I would uh after
January 6 I would send people pictures
of like the C what happened with
Kavanagh with people inside and people
would be like oh that didn't happen no
no I'd see like yes like when this
happened they're like yes look how awful
that is I'm like yes look how awful that
is yeah you remember when Amy Schumer
like occupied the Supreme Court and got
arrested remember when Jane Fonda every
Friday decided to get arrested outside
the capital for climate change and she
would like fly her jet in from La so she
could sit on the steps of Congress and
get arrested what a fool these people
are but they don't care about the
contradictions I mean that's the thing
about Democrats is they just don't seem
to be either aware of the contradictions
or they just don't care they're aware no
I used to fall into that camp like like
if you look at like I I always reference
the the Instagram account defiant L's
which always posts the people who
contradict themselves often times just
like a day later I used to be like look
maybe these people are just dumb they're
not dumb they're evil right they do not
care because look what they said first
reached a certain amount of people when
they post that second thing that
contradicts what they said completely
that reaches a whole another demographic
of people maybe 10 of maybe 10 20% of
those people see the contradiction but
they're so ideologically captured
anyways it doesn't matter maybe you
change maybe 5% of those people see it
and say wow I I don't know if I fall in
line with that uh that seems like a
contradiction but they don't care yeah
they're not they're not worried about it
it's like what is it it's like hierarchy
not uh not hypocrisy it doesn't matter
to them yeah if hierarchy hierarchy not
hypocrisy what does that mean it means
that the people who are committing these
hypocrisies they are sort of blatantly
doing it to show you that they're above
it that it doesn't matter that they're
being critical that truth is Tru is
malleable that reality is as they see it
not how you see it there doesn't need to
I mean and it's like there doesn't need
to be a value system if you just you
know it's just this constant shifting
ideological sand and it doesn't matter
where you stand it doesn't you can't
build anything on it so they just come
up with what's that the gold post are
moving anyways yeah the gold post are
moving anyway so they it's like oh I
scored well the gold post are over there
not anymore now they're here I've even
heard more insane rationalizations that
say look if they were to make those
contradictions in their personal life
with friends and family that would be
bad but in the service of political
agenda it's okay because it's in service
to maintaining power and the only thing
that matters is maintaining and that's
and if that's not the definition of evil
I don't know what that's evil well
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
that I think we could Define as evil but
for sure that's one of them yeah yeah
that in the evil of the crowds who get
together and commit Mass violence just
because they think it's fun or yeah just
because they're they're spurred on
remember I remember when I was a kid and
there would be always um there were
always these stories about people being
trampled in India and it would be like
or in Saudi Arabia or like at Mecca or
something and it would always be just
like you you know somebody sneezed and
the crowd went wild and 200 people got
trampled to death I always wondered how
does this happen how do you all just
start bugging out like that and think
about that now in cities like New York
City where there's so many people
congregated in such small space like
that's just to me what it is like we've
built these cities up so high now that
it's like yes uh a a large majority of
those people may be able to with
withstand the idea of falling victim to
crowd mentality right but you're putting
yourself at risk every day by being
around it well the thing about New York
and crowd mentality is there's ways that
you behave within the crowd of New York
City that you would never behave
somewhere else like um you know where I
live now people say hi to each other and
in New York if you said hi to everybody
you passed you'd never get where you
were going you know you never make eye
contact with anybody which is still
something that I do it's like I'm never
going to make eye contact with strangers
because what if they're crazy and then
I'm in their line of sight and the next
thing you know you know you're a Target
of the crazy person just because you
looked at them or they're trying to
fundra for a nonprofit and as soon as
you lock they got you that's terrible
and like look and not just like if you
come from a small town and you go to New
York City they and you do greet someone
they don't say hello they say who's this
right like why are you talking to me go
away you have to get used to the
different different social setting
different one of the things that I
always found so interesting about New
York is how people's private lives
unfold in public you know you'll see
somebody just in tears on the subway
people just walk by like no and you know
and like there have been times when I've
been literally like sobbing on the
subway and an old woman will hand me a
tissue and be like are you okay so we we
have some breaking updates CNN is now
reporting 16 people have died in Leon
main with 50 to 60 injuries wow they're
investigating multiple active shooter
events a suspect remains at large we are
encouraging all businesses to lock down
or close while we investigate main State
Police also said they responding to an
active shooter situation on Facebook
please lock your doors so so the concern
is it looks like it's multiple uh uh
areas this could be one person and who's
moved to different areas but some people
are concerned it's more than one person
uh according like from I've read in the
chat at least I know the report said
there was Middle Eastern men uh lot of
the chat I don't I don't I no there's a
there's a photo that was released that
could be a person of Middle Eastern
descent um I encourage people to just to
look for these official news sources and
thenit till make a determination for
yourself don't make assumptions about
what you think a person looks like look
at the actual photo but I'm concerned
that there there are fake accounts
spreading this specifically to Fan the
Flames of of of a conflict so that could
be it right so watch out for that yep
Hannah Nightingale who's working on this
story right now at post millennial is
from Maine and she's saying well that's
she's normally not on this late but if
it's a main thing she you know she'll
come check it out but I was just there
yeah she she said that there's never
been a mass shooting like this in Maine
before there not a lot of people yeah
it's like the biggest city in Maine is
like 40,000 people or something little
it's a little I mean it's a big state
with not that many people in it as you
just said y That's the whole thing well
I don't know man if you're in Maine yeah
right but if if you know if Maine isn't
safe this what are the gun laws why
we're in West Virginia right West
Virginia like has its issues too but at
least in West Virginia you can have guns
right can you have guns the main pass a
reckless permitless carry law says gords
I'm just reading it that's what gford
says yeah that's why I pointed out
initially that I'm I'm reading this from
the internet uh permitless carry law
2015 that allows residents to carry
concealed without a permit or background
check that's 2A so um and in in 2021 M
had the 14th lowest gun death rate wow
interesting so that's actually pretty
interesting what's gord's I don't even
know what that Gabby gords oh that's
Gabby gords oh right because she was
shot in the head so you know she's
worried about gun loss makes sense once
you're shot in the head but well she's
not I think she's evil because she has
armed security guards and gets
government protection and then tries to
deny it for everyone else so she has
guns they're just being held by other
people what she's actually saying is
only we may have cake hierarchy not
hypocrisy do the do the people who
protect California politicians have to
adhere to California gun laws as far as
like magazine size usually they uh this
is how it works right so like in
Venezuela during the protests if you're
if you're on the side of the government
you're getting a Full Belly every night
and that's why they do it everyone else
is starving and they tell you you want
to be starving with them and protesting
go ahead and do it you want a full belly
you take the gun you stop them from
protesting that when when you like these
people who who uh protect politicians
have restrictions often they have to
when like they they're allowed to carry
their gun only while they're on duty but
10 round mags they're allowed to have a
gun at their house or something like
that in a lot of states that make it
very difficult to do yeah oh and they
probably get special benefits like that
for sure yeah yeah Illinois which was
always super restrictive H but if you're
if you're protecting the politicians
you're good then you're all right to do
it yeah if you're if you're a cop you're
good if you're part of the machine and
protecting the people in power you're
good everyone else it's all about power
it's always all about just maintaining
power of course you know well yeah for
whatever reason for whatever reason I
mean I just don't understand that kind
of it's amazing how it just always kind
of plots out that way but not everybody
has this uh uh this this mental state
ambition drift no that's not absolutely
not it like the I have plenty of
ambition but I'm not interested in
maintaining power yeah I mean ambition
doesn't mean killing people for personal
gain or causing Mass suffering like no
no this that's I mean yeah what what
what what some there are people out
there that are just they Revel in
causing suffering of others yeah totally
mhm hence why there's probably a mass
shooting right now that's another evil
thing wanting to cause harm wanting to
hurt people like uh like pulling a fire
alarm to stop Congress right that's
horrifying evil how does he live with
himself I think he does just fine so
there going to they're going to drop the
charges I think he should go to jail I
think he should definitely go he get
community Ser community service have to
serve it with Jenna Ellis together
that's what they should do make a
reality show about it let's talk about
evil let's do it from The Daily Mail Las
Vegas teens Jesus Ayala and yasmir keys
laugh in court and give the finger to
the family of police chief they filmed
thems mowing down and killing you
remember this video a hor went viral
They're laughing in their car filming it
and they Ram this guy from behind and
they're in court and they're laughing
about it dude I'm sorry they're messing
around they're just yeah they just don't
care about anything or all the way
outside the CL out as they were being
walked out basically still laughing well
they were laughing just sitting
there I find yeah I I don't know how you
I mean I think it's important to be able
to understand how people get to this
point and how this happens but I also
think that we've and I think evil of
course has always existed I mean you
could go back to Genesis like it's right
there you know yeah um killing your
brother for jealous because you're
jealous or whatever that happens um but
I I I do think that we have
neglected our you know spiritual life in
this country to a certain extent I think
that it it's not a good thing that we
have elevated atheism and that we have
expected the you know judeo-christian
moral codes as exemplified by you know
primarily
the Commandments The Gospel according to
Matthew um you know the Beatitudes there
I think it's a problem that we have
expected those things to survive in
public life uh We've expected the Civil
religion that maintains public Society
to survive while
removing God entirely and while removing
you know the concept of a higher power
that will hold you accountable and that
will also not just hold you accountable
that will hold you accountable and
provide you light and love you you know
and communion with your with your fellow
man I think that that's a big problem
like how do you this is a conversation
I've been having with my son a great
deal lately who's studying for his
confirmation next year um and definitely
says to me things like I don't know if I
believe in God and I'm like okay you
know enjoy your CCD class because you
know we're teaching you this anyway um
and I had you know a very long period of
toying with atheism myself until the
void was just too much the void was too
much I just I could no longer look into
that void and step out into the world
and look at the Sun and be happy about
it so but I think that um I think that
as we have removed God and as we have
removed spiritual feelings we have uh
eradicated them to the point where it's
hard to find them like how are the kids
supposed to find God if they never even
learn the word I was talking to and then
I'm going to let you talk I just have
one more thing I say I was um I was at
TPA something not this past June but the
previous June and I was on a panel with
um Carol Martz and Emma Joe Morris and
it was really fascinating and we were
talking about how to maintain you know
your religious traditions and your faith
while you're living in essentially New
York City where we lived yeah um and a
young woman got up and she said you know
most of us in my generation don't know
anything we know we don't know from God
we don't understand any of this I
instead when we have a spiritual crisis
we think it's psychological and we go
get therapy and we just end up with
drugs so how do you how do you find God
if God has been eradicated and how do
you maintain a moral Center if there is
nothing to ground it yeah do you do you
find that religion is uh in in the time
that you've been alive if you found like
the the the decrease in religion here in
America to be one of the main calling
cards for wise Society seems to be
falling the way it
has yes yeah um I can remember
when there was and I think lib you make
a very important
Point everyone sort of
agreed on the basics of ethical
Behavior but the feeling was well we
don't we don't have to be
so doire about religious faith we can
you know you don't even really need to
be religious to acknowledge that killing
is bad and uh you know stealing is
bad but it turns out that that's not
true it turns out that that's not true
at all because we see widespread
justification of killing and we see
stealing both of those are both highly
Justified now in society right
um and this is something that I
discussed and in fact I discussed it
with uh with
um uh at length with with our mutual
friend um on the Sheamus on the shamer
cast
shast after we after we met here when
you were pretending to be sick so
you skip
work
um it is extremely difficult because you
know he he's a he's an orthodox Catholic
and I'm an orthodox Jew
and we were talking
about you know we might all agree as a
completely objective sociological
observation that
societies that do have religious Faith
are more stable
and there might be aspects of it but you
what do you do if people have lost their
faith as a societ when as an entire
Society well you know that didn't really
necessarily work I mean you know oh I
was
kidding oh no I I you know if it worked
then we would have to you know but
actually remember the main issue with
with the Inquisition was
identifying Jews who pretended to be
converts um but you can't even really
talk about Orthodoxy anymore in other
words we're we're we're in a we're in a
post Orthodoxy World unless you live in
a subculture as I do in which
we have created our own governing mores
and that it's not perfect and it's not
entirely always consistent but be
because of the the extent of Liberty
that Americans are
permitted and most people in the west
are permitted we can we can do that and
we have our own internal governance
systems and our own rabinal Courts for
civil disputes and again everything
doesn't click the way it necessarily
ought to
but what can you do to an entire society
that doesn't even have
that feeling that because you know Libby
you identified you know you'd reached a
point in your life when you said
this I'm going to paraphrase you now
this can't be what it's all about this
we're just an
arbitrary F of the
universe there must be meaning there
must be a reason and there must be truth
must there must be somewhere that love
comes from was also what I was thinking
and you still had resonating in you a
family tradition of where to look to
recover the
the you know the methodology and the
language and the thinking of what the
answers to these questions were so my
friend um yuram honei writes in his you
know books about conservatism and
National
conservatism it is a legitimate thing
for people to look to the faith of their
ancestors people think well how do you
know Judaism how do if you would have
been born a Hindu I
wasn't I wasn't I just know that the
people that I respect and the and the
tradition and the culture that I look to
my ancestors toward and I see people who
were older than I
they are a product of a tradition that
is entitled to a presumption of validity
for me because I am myself also a
product of that that's very hard for
Americans to get onto because Americans
have this admirable quality of
questioning everything yeah and being
skeptical and show me state I'm from
Missouri you know and
it turns out that these those are
good exercises to participate in but you
if you don't have a base at which you
say this is never
permitted and and also you know there's
there there's such a lack of
understanding of basic theological
Concepts that have been treated at Great
length for thousands of years and people
go to college and they think they
they've you know they've got these
really clever answers to Great
theological questions and they
don't and they think it's really a good
question so you think God really cares
whether you uh eat bacon or
not I do and you know why because God
has the capacity to care about
everything at once he's not limited like
you are by trying to multitask he's God
uh
and and it would be great if you know
May and you know there probably are
people who do this if people could you
know could could get a B basic
theological
education uh and just understand if they
want to be Skeptics what they're being
skeptical of but it's a hard it's a real
hard task what are the ramifications
for uh defying God in Judaism
is in traditional
Judaism there are several kinds of
punishments that are discussed uh in the
Torah one is that if you uh you can be
punished by an
Earthly um court
for knowingly violating God's law now
you can also in the time of the of the
temple you know the Great temple of
Palestine in Jerusalem uh that you could
you would bring a sacrifice you'd have
to bring a sacrifice because
you know that that's laid out in the you
know in the Bible as how you atone for a
sin you have to go through the trouble
of buying an
animal and having it you know and it
doesn't have to be a big old cow it
could be a bird it could it could even
just be meal if you're if you're if
you're a poor person you need to say to
God I I'm making a donation I'm I am
paying a penalty and I want and and and
you're gonna you fine what if you don't
if you don't then all right let's your
question really is more spiritual not
right so you can be punished in this
world which is considered to be a good
scenario in other words you would rather
be punished In This World by afflictions
than have your punishment await you in
the next world because there's no
limitation to what suffering you can uh
experience in the next but is this the
same notion of Heaven and Hell
essentially essentially it is I mean
there are you know and there's a lot of
I I will tell you that the the
traditional Jewish thinking on this has
reflected in the talmid and this is
going to get your live chat going they
love words like that
um the the rabbis are absolutely
comfortable with the idea of reward and
Punishment in the in this world in the
next World we also have the uh the
concept of the
um the
the that the dead will come will come
back to life in the time of you know of
the
Messiah you can be deprived of the
opportunity to be resurrected if you if
if you are guilty of certain certain
kinds of sins um which would be you know
that would be pretty bad but then
there's you know there's a soul the soul
is not the body the soul is not you it's
not some you know it's not some mag
magnetic force or something it's it is
it is a a Godly Essence that is placed
with within you and it's you can suffer
in this world you can suffer in the next
World very comp you know much much more
complex stuff than people would think
and you find you know and it is
reflected in Christianity it's reflected
certainly the cath the Catholic church
was founded by rabinal students and they
knew what you know they knew what they
were talking about we're going to go to
super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash SM that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to
timcast.net
today Clint but unfortunately you are
third all right Shane H Wilder says I
feel good about Mike Johnson his report
card seems pretty outstanding that and
if Adam Schiff hates him he must be
doing something right I also love that
people were like people on Twitter were
like sharing like Mike Johnson Super
Cuts I'm like did you guys just have
these ready to go who's making like
these like probably to be fair there are
people I mean I will whip out a a
gif in 90 seconds yeah if if if if the
if if you know if the occasion strikes
me if you know if you if you you have
the software on the phone and you know
how to do it and you would rather play
hookie and you know and stay up late to
finish your homework as I would you guys
at work his boss is like got to get the
work done he's like I'm making this Mike
Johnson super cut can you hold on he's
like who the hell is Mike Johnson Leroy
Hall says can you shout out my wife
Trina Halls give send go please she's
sick with systemic Scleroderma that is
advancing fast thank you and God bless
y'all well shout out I I hope things
work out for you does it say what the
what was the name Trina Hall t r i n a
give send
go the emperor's Champion says not first
I know but I highly recommend the book
what Justice demands by Elana Jero it's
a well- researched in-depth objective
look into the Israel Palestine conflicts
I can't recommend it more I read uh a
decent bit about uh the history of the
region today the problem is you read
this and then you ask someone who's Pro
Palestine and say that's all fake that
never happened and you're like well I
tell you man
there you
go Andrew Russ says I'm still salty Tim
didn't like the latest Dune it's Game of
Thrones in space it is Game of Thrones
in space that takes 4 hours of dead air
to get to the point look I I'll be like
we went that night and and we left early
right we walked out the we walked out of
the the like I I I would have been fine
sing I ended up watching it later um on
on HBO Max and I didn't hate it as much
as you did but I I don't mind the Slow
Burn as much and denal Noob is like one
of my favorite directors working so SL
bur it's very slow bur and there's no
ending it's like well we're going to be
making another one it's like I I
understand that like I I've got the bias
because the director is one of those
directors who's just whose work is one
that I really like but also just the
fact that he that's the project he
wanted to direct like his whole life so
I had a little bit of bias there but I I
am sad that they delayed part two cuz I
actually do hope to see it in the
theaters and supposedly it will be at
least a little bit shorter well it works
at home you just fast forward yeah you
just Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip
okay I just I watch movie like that
that's shot that beautifully and I can
seeing it on the big screen is just
there are a handful of shows where it's
like I'm glad it's on Netflix because it
starts off really good and then get as
it gets weaker I just I find myself
skipping oh Netflix is the worst for
that like they they made this movie this
benil Del Toro movie called reptile that
I just watched and it was what is it
about it's this awful crime drama where
it's like he's investigating the murder
of a of a the girlfriend of some typ
type of real estate developer played by
listening to you describe it yeah played
by Justin timberl and it's just it's the
it's even slower than what you described
as dune but like almost Justin Timberly
yes oh he's he acts too have you tried
watching bodies no you heard it right I
I couldn't do it I'm hearing like oh
this new show on Netflix is so good and
then I'm like play and then within five
minutes I was like well that was dumb
and turned it off Netflix has got a very
low hit rate lately other than the the
bigger
ones look they they Miss on everything
but like yeah they like when they try to
do the any of the stuff they've done
with their spy Thrillers the one with
galgadot really really bad the ones they
did with the Russo Brothers really
really bad not good Ben Hancock says
question for Tim do you read all of the
super chats after the show or only the
ones that you read live if your question
is after we close out the show do I sit
there and then go through every single
Super Chat the answer is no once the
show wraps up we do the members only
show and then I go to
sleep we however on pop culture crisis
do read all the super chats and if it
keeps us late it keeps us late and uh
it's gon to go later and later and later
no it does it does his his audience they
also do a thing where like if I look
like I want to go they start super
chatting more just to keep me there
don't they keep you there like every
Super chat keeps you there another 10
minutes depends on how much like but the
problem is by the end I'm like so out of
it I'm like starting to slur my words
cuz my blood sugar has absolutely
collapsed and I need to eat so they get
a huge kick out of watching me suffer
it's fantastic oh wow so there is evil
in the world there is evil in the world
exactly exactly it's it's fantastic and
we love them for it all right what do we
have the text vet says Johnson said in
his acceptance speech the first thing to
be done is to give money to Israel yeah
that's what I saw I thought that was
that was that was what happened and so
uh it's a question of I thought he said
to support
Israel did he actually say to give money
to Israel well he probably said to to
provide support for Israel but it's same
thing right um I I suppose I guess I
guess it might be a euphemism for for
giving money yeah it's a bigger question
about are we going to be funding
escalation of War are we going to be
providing support in the form of like
Iron Dome batteries which we've already
done so I think the bigger concern is
are we driving ourselves towards World
War III or greater regional conflict at
at you know how about we balance the
budget how about we secure our Southern
border how about we end all foreign sure
and there's that Meme there's a meme
where it's uh it's the the wojack who's
like all depressed looking and it's
Janet Yen saying we can afford two Wars
and he's like I just want Healthcare
it's the yeah or it's the it's like it's
like uh
Ukraine uh Israel and then and then the
American people are just
underwater in the meme yeah yep all
right where we at Jack the r says
American Jewish people utilize that
second amendment buy arms and Munitions
and train be safe get out of those
garbage cities that's what was saying
too like I love it when you know the
left is like uh there's the meme of the
white guy and the black guy and and it's
the it's like the Chad wo Jacks and he's
like nice gun and the black guy's like
nice gun you want to go shoot they're
like yeah and then they're both shooting
together and then the leftist is like no
you're supposed to be racist they was
just shooting guns together we went to
the shooting range and there was like
people of all different backgrounds
there there was a couple of black guys
and there were some Middle Eastern guys
and there was a bunch of white guys and
everyone was laughing had a good time
and pointing at the guns and high and
I'm like see this is diversity right
joining together in great enjoyment of
firing guns and they brought in a fully
automatic one and people are like was so
much fun shot on Saturday first time in
five years hor hor just like like they
say you don't use it you lose it yeah I
I am not particularly good with handguns
I think the best I was able to do it
like 30 yards was two out of seven yeah
but with the the various long guns like
my accuracy was very very good but
admittedly very easy to you know
relative to uh like handguns harder like
we were shoo like like I don't remember
the 9mm having this much
kick depends on the one you're using I
guess y all right where we at a green
Clover says biggest issue facing Europe
is the ammunition shortage in
conventional Warfare UK has one week
France has four days and Germany has two
days wow okay but again meanwhile Russia
has been building its reserves of ammo
and military indust industrial
complex
interesting cam girl lasuna says Libby
one ship was damaged by an Iranian mine
once in the 80s and was later repaired
in response Reagan sent a task force
that ended up sinking or disabling half
of Iran's Navy in a mere eight hours got
it woo good times that's what I call
nice disproportionate attack stay the
Serge loves the
yes thrust MC trunk punch says on the
Iran dinghy in response to the dinghy
being sunk our Navy destroyed half of
Iran in eight hours Iran in eight hours
they claimed it was proportional
response I think that's some
disproportionate response but doesn't it
make sense to have a disproportionate
response cuz doesn't it like keep people
away from you like if you
like no the whole proportionality thing
is complete like stay the hell
away Donald Trump was always about like
hey if you do that I'm going to Nuke you
and it's like that is a disproportionate
response and a crazy it's a little crazy
but listen the thing about Trump is he's
a little crazy and that keeps us good
and safe CU you know what you don't do
you don't mess with the crazy guy on the
corner you don't look him in the eye you
just stay away and you hope you don't
get shot that's what I like about Trump
aligan news says Russia started
modernizing its nuclear and Conventional
Weapons starting in 2000 they have
completed 89% by 2020 don't
underestimate the
bear there you
go oh well I just want to keep the
country safe and the Border closed and
then we're good Mr nobody says Tim did
you have World War III on your October
surprise bingo card Mean Tweets were
better than this in every conceivable
way yeah Steve McGee says Nazi schwein
hun or in German Nazi says what Luke
says what schwein hund means pig dog yes
they were they were calling him a Nazi
Pig it means like bastard yep they were
insulting him for no reason literally no
reason luk is walking on the street and
some guy just points him and called him
a Nazi did they recognize him nope I
have no I I well it's possible but
unlikely considering random people just
started hitting him yeah so uh there
something did happen where there was a
photo of uh well I I don't want to say
too much because it involves other
people's private security so I I'll keep
it I I'll keep the general story out of
it but the general idea that Luke
published was that he was walking with a
German journalist and this guy Max and
then someone just yelled Nazi Nazi
schwein hund and so it's the craziest
thing I'm like why did that guy started
hitting you like I have no idea gu just
really hated we are chang.org but think
about what this means if you go to if if
a if if like let's say a right-wing
person dresses up like antifa goes to an
antifa rally and then just starts
pointing at a random guy saying that's
that's John Smith like literally at love
this rally make up a name Chad furton
like that's Chad furton dude he's a Nazi
I don't know if that would work at
antifa because I think that they're
actually extremely well organized it'll
work you think so Absol absolutely I
think they're well organized too but I
also think you're not going to pull it
off in a group of seven antifa in a
group of 500 they'll just start
mercilessly beating whoever gets pointed
at maybe right they what'll happen is
they'll be hey bro who are you what's
going on man who are you like someone
will walk up after hearing that and then
start pushing the guy and being like
show me your phone show me your like and
the guy's goingon to be like dude I'm
not a Nazi like he's a not and and then
they just it's a it's an avalanche it's
I've like like I mentioned watch the
videos out of San Jose from like 20156
of people just chasing each other
through the streets I watch them beat
elderly people they'll just that's just
the way it goes so nuts they all at
Occupy Wall stre like every March
something like that happened someone
would just run up and hit somebody
because someone accused them I remember
when that was happening I did not go to
occupy yeah I was home with my kid for a
couple years I had no idea what was
going on cuz I just had a small
child it was lovely someone want to pull
up the latest data on uh what's going on
in in in Leon so it's 22 and they have
um is covering this confirmed dead right
yeah 22 confirmed dead and they released
a picture of the car is it a maroon SUV
no it's a little hatchback okay and that
that's the thing because that's what I
was saying the people who are saying
maroon SUV in Middle Eastern may have
been fake and if they're saying it's not
that then likely someone was putting out
fake information right but I will
say you know the description of the man
is seen the photographs yeah it those
now swarthy is that the description uh
uh not I wouldn't describe the person as
white they appear on on the surveillance
photos to be potentially of Middle
Eastern Hispanic you know like slight
lightly darker skin but if he's hispanic
that would be wide adjacent yes he he
can be Hispanic I'm just trying to
describe a guy who's who's a mass
shooter I'm not trying to make a joke
you know like I'm just saying like in in
in terms of politics like yeah might be
a middle eastern there's a press com
conference coming up right they said
that the police I think chief police but
they have not caught the guy no don't
think so I think so at large JJ r Road
sorry there a thing on the screen says
how long has timit police has released
the suspect's name apparently whoa and
what is it Robert card Robert card yeah
well how are we supposed to figure out
what ethnicity that is now to I don't
know really every everyone's trying to
generate you know everyone wants to get
their their politics in I mean I don't
it's
unconfirmed JJ says police have released
that name sorry they did not police
release that name police have released
the suspect's name as Robert card what's
the source on that um raw alerts uh but
I don't know if that's accurate right
yeah raw alerts Raw May accurate we use
them periodically press conference yeah
I tend to grab them and then go digging
for what they said yeah and ands like
that ra Ros alerts I find to actually
line up properly with with other
official news reporting it's it's it's
hard to know who to trust I I mean no
disrespect to Ros alerts I'm not
familiar uh too much uh JJ Ro says Tim
pool Crowder Shapiro going gray uh when
did we all get so old uh gradually and
then suddenly I have never an
incremental evil is what it is aging the
only thing works is the alternative
people don't know this about Ron but
he's always looked this way even when he
was
15 even when I didn't look this way I
looked well I've heard like with aging a
lot of it's like it's like you feel like
you don't age like year by year it's
like you look the same for like 5 years
and then one year you age a bunch all at
once yeah and and people are asking
about me I I am part Asian which means
there will come a period where one day
I'll just be hunched over and
small that's the meme that's the mem
well you know what's amazing is I'm 60
years old and I thought by this age I
would already sound like
this that's what happens you know when
my brother was my brother is a is Korean
and um when he was like 16 I used
to uh is my dad listening I used to take
him I used to take him to clubs in New
York and take him out with my friends
and my friends would be like oh which
one of you is the older sibling and I'd
be like oh my God I'm literally 12 years
older than my brother and he'd be like
I'm Asian so you don't know and then
he'd like go hit on my friends and I'd
be like oh my God like my friends are 25
and here's my little brother and he's
like he had game it was impressive but
when I when I was a freshman I I I had a
beard I've always been robust in that
way and if you're 18 and you can grow a
full beard you grow a full beer and I
remember I was moving into my dorm and
and some upper classman was in there
says can you believe all the Freshman
moving in here and and you know I yeah
get
out all right we got a bunch of people
uh we got a bunch of people posting
about uh Lewiston main situation
developing a lot of super
chats thanks for uh uh posting will says
a swastika was drawn in inside Bates
College in Le uh Leon bathroom a few
days ago graduated from Bates a few
years ago leftist Haven crazy
Administration and faculty none of this
surprises
me yeah how does the media end up
covering it then does it get pivoted to
uh talk about gun crime you know here's
a thing normally I'd say if this guy
turns out to in any other circumstance
if this guy was a leftist who was acting
on this it'd be covered up in moments
like we saw with um was it Covington
Catholic so and uh was it nville NV
Nashville I don't think it Wasington
noing Kentucky right that was I totally
confused those the I forget the I forget
the name of the national you look theal
one yeah I will look it up but uh
considering if if it turns out this was
a leftist motivated by Israel Palestine
they absolutely will release the news on
this Covenant Covenant schol that's why
you thought yeah Covington because it's
very similar if if it turns out this guy
is motivated by the Israel Palestine
conflict and it was Pro pal sign they
will release this in 2 seconds I am not
suggesting that it is I am not saying
that there's evidence to suggest it is
I'm saying if in the you know whatever
astronomical chance it was they would be
like you see we're at risk we have to go
to war blah blah blah we have to go with
to war with main with Iran they'd say
Iran did it these are the Iranian
militias that that proves it there you
go well there's there is a press
conference coming up uh when let's
see
I'm Beth uh Beth bash who's doing social
media right now is like sharing stuff
well we'll read some more Super chats
yeah gaming entity says veterans who are
younger female in lgbtq are reporting
more mental health issues study finds
interesting interesting cheris says dare
you to have Norman finlin or Abby Martin
I don't understand why you would say
dare you to have I don't I don't like I
I don't get that like as if we don't
constantly invite people on the left to
come on the show we had Max Blumenthal
on the show last week it was a fantastic
conversation um and there's literally
five shows a week plus the culture War
there's a lot of show to we have a big
culture War this Friday yeah yeah I oh
he yeah very big who's on it uh I guess
we should just say it it's Wednesday um
Jen yuger oh wow yeah coming on culture
War just me and him we're going to talk
it's going to be great you going to ask
him about the dogs but the dogs yeah the
dogs do the dogs wasn't he the one
talking about how it should be okay to
have sex with dog with your horse I am
not okay uh if he bring they all have I
would like to situation where he brings
it up he's like and by the way I want to
get this out there right now
M
Virginia options are opening up they
might not have been available for him
driving here this is exactly what I'm
trying to avoid if we're going to have a
real conversation where he's going to
address the stance takes on his show the
politics of today what he what he thinks
this country should or shouldn't be
doing and the fact that is a massive
audience to do it we should have a real
conversation not bring up some stupid
comment he made 10 years ago as like a
what like a WWE haha I gotcha so
definitely not uh I'm glad that he's
coming we've invited him on the show
numerous times for a long time and he's
agreed to come on and it's going to be
awesome and uh I I guess someone said he
announced it on his show but no one was
really talking about it and you know
whatever we have a poster you know me
and him and we're just going to we're
going to talk and I wonder how long the
conversation will go but I imagine it'll
go for a while I've known the guy for a
long time and uh should be interesting
that'll be cool but yeah in terms of
like Abby Martin or anybody else the
answer is yes uh you whatever that
that's kind of the point we have this we
have this culture War show and shout out
to tenant media the culture war is uh is
moving over to tenet which has a bunch
of really awesome people involved I
don't know if you guys saw the the
announcement there's Benny Johnson Dave
ruin lawren
Southern uh Tyler
Hansen yeah is it Tyler or am I Taylor
Hansen why did I say Tyler I'm like I
missed a letter in his name for whatever
reason but uh uh yeah really really cool
stuff I can elaborate more on later but
the culture war is moving uh to tenet
and uh there's some good reasons for it
maybe we'll Library a little bit more on
the members only but we'll read some
more Super chats from now do you know
when that press conference is uh I'm
it's up right now it's not the press
conference yet it's basically new people
talking while they wait for the press
conference maybe we'll have that in the
member seg we'll try to get up as soon
as we can but uh yeah really cool stuff
Friday's going to be really really
awesome um glad to have Jen and I I hope
we have a calm legitimate conversation
when we had Banna woo on I thought that
it was very very calm and interesting
there were a lot of people like how
could you be so patient or whatever and
I was like I thought Brana was uh was
very polite and then afterward uh Brana
played poker with us and enjoyed Sushi
it was very it was good is excellent I
hope that uh Jen sticks around and hangs
out with everybody and I'm sure he's
actually got people who uh at some point
we're big fans and maybe in recent time
with the shift in politics don't really
watch him anymore but I think it'll be a
very good
conversation I think he's going to find
that a lot of people here completely
agree with him on like 60% of his
positions and then the more tribal
culture War stuff is where PE where he
loses a lot of people and in terms of
our crew because I imagine he's going to
say something like we shouldn't be going
to war and blah we're like yes we
completely yes that's absolutely right
yeah let's unify on those grounds that's
why it was great when Max came cuz it's
like hey look we may disag age on all
these things but if we agree on like
stopping these foreign invasions and
this this this war stuff then that's
what we should focus on and then worry
about the other stuff and I'm like I
agree let's win where we we all agree we
want to
win Greg Kerr says Tim we are still
raising funds for the Cumberland skate
park can we get you guys up there when
we finally get it open next year yes
who's building it do you uh we should we
should talk about who's uh who's
building it um we're big fans of the
spawn Ranch guys so uh you know where's
Cumberland Cumberland is like like an
hour west of here okay it's like little
it's an awesome little town yeah it's in
it's in the the the panhandle of
Maryland or whatever they call it it's a
cool place I went to a coin shop there
and that's where I got the the coin from
uh for Sheamus that was the same
currency used by St
Casper yeah I we we want to believe it
was one of the ones used by St Casper we
don't know that it's like a little
ancient coin from and you would expect
to find that
in Awesome Town in
Maryland you know you never know if God
wants it to be there then it could be
there the collector shop actually had a
bunch of really cool stuff I mean they
had like Confederate money we we have
like that bank note right there yeah I
was thinking about that yeah it's a pre-
Federal Reserve Bank note that comes
from that same same collector shop and
we got Confederate money we got old Bank
notes cool place and I got I got a uh a
silver coin from ancient Greece that's
like rated at like 9.5 or whatever it is
in it's crazy they they they had very
little Precision so it's like an oddly
shaped metal disc they stamp yeah oh
it's in the closet I'll pull it out in a
second we will grab it we'll show it off
super cool stuff all right so we got a
lot of super chats just talking about
Maine which that press conference is
coming up we'll talk about it all right
raino says I hear a lot about Julian
Assange but have you forgotten about
Schaefer Cox if you haven't heard of him
please look into him he's been in a
black site prison for decades now for
fighting for what's right I'm not
familiar you know I I I I I did this
thing earlier where I talked about Jenna
Ellis and then Julian nange Andrew
claven said that you know he thinks it's
funny UNP paraphrasing that all these
people think they would be great Heroes
and stand up against Injustice because
Jen Alis took this plea agreement and my
response is just like I feel like it's a
cop out you know which which is a cop
out what Andrew claven is saying Jenna
Ella like oh these little boy he said
little boys in capes think they're
fighting monsters something like that
cuz Jenna Ellis took this plea agreement
and all these people are talking big
like they some great Martyrs and I'm
like yeah maybe half of them would I
don't know maybe half of them wouldn't
maybe some people are talking big game
but then I said look at Julian Assange
who's like they they're effectively
executing in solitary confinement for 10
years with fake charges and now
everything's going on because he refuses
to compromise Wikileaks and so if you
tell me who am I going to look up to and
who am I going to criticize this one's
really obvious Jenna Ellis was either
lying the whole time in support of trump
which she had admits to so maybe that's
the case or she was doing her
constitutional Duty in defending a her
client and c and a candidate in a
challenge to the election which they
they they believe was was a
constitutional challenge in which case
it's her duty to do and she decided to
betray her Duty in this country so pick
one Julian Assange will not give up his
sources no matter what even though
they've basically they're slow slow it's
going a slow roll execution of him so
I'll I'll I'll I'll leave it there and
we'll uh we'll grab a a couple a couple
more okay what do we
got uh well now just people commenting
on Lewis and Main a lot of lot of super
chats yeah story is getting Wilder as as
many minutes going are is there any more
developments um people are I mean
there's a lot of speculation I don't
know if I want to like say anything
confirmed we'll get the press conference
up in the members only so let's do this
uh smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show go to
timcast.net I'm sorry the membersonly
show at Tim cast.com and we're gonna
we're going to pull up the uh the uh uh
the the press conference and then talk
about it we'll be a little bit more
spicy because it's going to be not so
familyfriendly you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Ron do you want to
shout anything out at Ron Coleman you
can go and uh you can hear me say things
uh and and watch me uh tweet things and
it will cost you
nothing you will benefit
immeasurably guys if you want to follow
me you can follow me on Instagram and
Twix at Brett dvic on both of those
platforms but also remember pop culture
crisis is Monday through Friday 3 pm
Eastern Standard Time noon Pacific I
think Libby's going to be on with us
this Friday oh I think so yes so it's a
lot of fun you guys should come hang out
with us uh I'm Libby Emmons you can find
me on Twitter at Libby emons you can
check out all the great work we're doing
at the poost
millennial.age SL
subscribe and I am surge.com Baba it's
kind of hard to say that while we have
the situation going on in Maine if you
guys are looking for more information if
you're not joining us in the after show
look up Andre scogin County Sheriff's
Office they are the ones doing it's a n
d r o c o gg iin peace out have a good
night we'll see you all over at
timcast.net
that